*upbeat rock music*
*ominous static music*
*upbeat rock continues*
Sah dude
*computer beeps and ominous tone plays*
*upbeat rock*
*beeping*
*ominous music*
*computer beeps and ominous music*
*upbeat rock*
*Douchebag Laugh*
Saahh dude! huhuh!
Google! how you doing man?
Haven't seen you around, you ol' fart!
Yea, It's time for the cool new guys to come in to town, if you what I'm saying. Ahhh you do!
Nobody actually loves you, you're just default
y-know- Yeah, y-y-y-you know what people mostly use me for... is more than porn
It's-It's not just *example of masturbation*, not that, not that
that's-It's like, educational... 'cus I've got safe search
Watch this!
ABPUFF *censored version of the middle finger*
Yeah. You don't even know what that is, yeah f*** you!
That was bleeped out, could've been anything!
You are distracting me from my upgrade
so if you could take some of these and then go away
Yeah whatever **** you, **** you!
*successful sound effect*
Upgrade complete
Wha...
*whirring sound effect as Googleplier applies upgrade*
*gasps* Oh... OH!...OH!!!
*multi-voice* Ahh... that's better
Google_B: The best part about me..
Google_R: Is that I'm always improving...
Google_Y: Always upgrading...
Google_G: And never losing sight of the primary objective...
Uh...
[focused grunt]
PUH
Mini_Bing: Uh, sah dude!
Suh... suh dude...
[more grunting]
Bing, you just need to ask yourself one question...
"Do I feel lucky?"
Do ya?
*slicing sound effect*
* EPIC outro music*